[Music]
i need to exchange some books
come scarlett's kid
how is your mother i haven't seen her in
15 years
let's get you into a cookbook you'll
need a jane austen
a virginia wolf and an agatha christie
for reading sam
your talents are needed
[Music]
somebody stole from us he's crazy enough
to steal from the fern
is it done there's a change of plan they
have an eight-year-old girl
i can't leave her to die
sam you killed the wrong people you're
no longer under our protection
some bad men are coming to hurt us we
have to go where it's safe
hi mom am i grandmother
god no
girls i think i see a ghost we need
weapons
give the kill order i'm gonna do
terrible things to you girls
we're gonna bring the sky down on their
heads
i'm gonna make a little noise
so what's the plan i called as an uber
are you kidding me nope
oh that's really unfortunate
if i get out of this alive i'm coming
for you
you are an incredibly impressive young
woman there's not a single person on
earth i'd rather kill people with
thanks mom
are you a serial killer what you kill
people
yes and you've killed more than one that
is cereal
it's more complicated than that
[Music]
you